daniel bilalian vous voyez ça comment la
suite pour l'instant ils sont
autonomistes n'est pas indépendantiste
et moi je vais partir de la position de
raymond barre vous souvenez de la
position de raymond barre qui disait
s'ils veulent l'indépendance qu'ils
l'apprennent c'est vrai que aux yeux
d'une majorité de français qui ne
connaissent pas forcément tous très très
très bien le dossier
on ne juge pas aux apparences mais elles
sont rarement trompeuse disait le
proverbe
ce qui peut être énervant c'est le fait
de vouloir être de voir l'autonomie mais
ne pas prévoir l'indépendance avant dix
ans on comprend plus bien si ces gens se
veulent juste l'autonomie de la corse ou
s'il prépare à l'indépendance ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
clair alors la seule chose positive
c'est qu'on a réussi à rassembler les
deux les deux des deux départements
corses ont un seul ce qui devrait se
faire dans beaucoup d'autres
départements français mais moi ce qui me
kim contrarie c'est toujours le
sentiment que les corses veulent venir
soyons clairs voulait être indépendant
vous voulez rester français c'est ce
qu'avait dit raymond barre mais cette
situation d'autonomie un peu comme on
peut la voir dans d'autres régions avec
moins - défait par exemple c'est le cas
de la bretagne ou des choses comme ça je
veux dire ce pays s'est rassemblée
autour d'une france unifié à la
révolution française où est-ce qu'on
veut la conserver comme ça sinon on va
t'on moi je vais vous donner un exemple
de cette espèce de foi de bêtises mais
de deux choses qui sont ridicules un peu
dans les rues de rennes aujourd'hui on a
des on a débaptisé les noms propres même
sous les noms sous les noms officiels il
ya nombre breton jacques cartier devenu
jacques aux cartes aux alors à quand
général de voile je veux dire ça n'a pas
de sens ça n'a pas de sens de dire ce
pays a eu du mal à ses assauts alors où
on en fait partie où on n'en fait pas
partie mais moi l'autonomie avec
l'indépendance dans dix ans on se dit le
français moyen se dit bon ce qu'ils ont
envie de conserver ses désavantages de
la france et prendre leur indépendance
par ailleurs sur beaucoup d'autres
sujets beaucoup de français pensent
aujourd'hui que les lakers bénéficient
et c'est pas faux d'un certain nombre
d'avantagés en termes d'impôts de taxes
etc etc et qui veulent les préserver
tout en voulant être à côté